[Música]
hay descontento y rabia en Irán así lo
han demostrado los ciudadanos en
múltiples manifestaciones en las calles
de toda la república islámica pero lo
que llama la atención es que algunas de
estas manifestaciones son encabezadas
por mujeres jóvenes una nueva generación
de mujeres que no fue testigo en su
momento de la Revolución islámica Estos
son algunos de los hechos principales
Todo comenzó con la muerte de la joven
masa a mini de 22 años cuando estaba
bajo custodia de la policía de la moral
a mini fue detenida por no llevar
correctamente el velo islámico su
fallecimiento fue digamos que El Punto
de partida para numerosas
manifestaciones que les estaba
comentando en diferentes ciudades que
hasta el momento según las cifras
oficiales han dejado 8 fallecidos pero
diferentes ong que tienen sede allí en
Irán dicen que esta cifra de fallecidos
podría superar los 30 ambas cifras son
cifras que todavía France 24 no ha
podido confirmar de manera
a raíz del malestar ciudadano el
gobierno entonces anunció que puso en
marcha una investigación sobre este caso
para ver en detalle qué fue lo que
sucedió con la joven masa a Mini y desde
un primer momento ha habido una condena
internacional por el fallecimiento de
esta joven también el trato que recibió
por parte de las autoridades y porque
volvió a quedar en evidencia a lo que
están expuestas las mujeres en esa
República islámica vamos a ver entonces
cómo están las cosas en terreno allí en
Teherán en la capital iraní está con
nosotros Catalina Gómez Ángel nuestra
corresponsal permanente en la capital de
Irán Catalina estamos en ante momentos
de efervescencia y también de
descontento general por parte de los
iraníes un momento que podemos decir es
un momento de coyuntura muy particular
al que se ha sumado entonces este
descontento a la raíz de la muerte de
esta joven iraní de solo 22 años
hay un poco de las dos la indignación la
rabia el descontento ha ido en aumento
en los últimos años no solamente por la
situación económica política sino social
muchos de esos jóvenes que están
actualmente en la calle piensan que no
hay futuro en el país y esto se agudiza
con la represión que de la cual han sido
objeto en los últimos meses
especialmente de la llegada a la
presidencia de Ibrahim raíz y que ha
sido bastante duro con mayor presencia
de esa policía la moral en las calles
los basilis presionando más no solamente
en las grandes ciudades sino en esos
pequeñas ciudades del país donde la
gente también se protesta y donde ven
incluso con mayor intensidad esa presión
del Estado Así que la muerte de maxa una
niña que viene de un pueblo de que viene
de una familia tradicional que no es
nadie de la clase alta de Teherán y rica
pues simplemente muere por ir en las
calles cuando estaba de visita Aquí en
Teherán y termina siendo no solamente
capturada sino que golpeaba como dicen
algunas versiones y termina por morir
esta indignación obviamente ha hecho que
esta rabia se haga mayor Y como dice una
de las personas que ha hablado en los
últimos días dices no es indignación
encontró un punto en común y esa Mini y
por eso estamos en las calles
protestando No solamente por su muerte
sino por la presión a la que todas y
todos estamos sometidos
Catalina estos hechos nos demuestran que
Tal parece que las mujeres iraníes están
perdiendo el miedo qué tan significativo
es que esta iniciativa de salir a las
calles de manifestarse venga por parte
de las mujeres iraníes
cada generación de estas últimas cuatro
décadas ha tenido su momento de protesta
y cada una de ellas ha perdido el miedo
en su momento y se ha atrevido a
protestar sin embargo la crueldad o la
fortaleza la agresividad con la que han
respondido las fuerzas del estado en
cada momento y cada vez incluso con
mayor intensidad hacen no solamente que
vuelvan a sus casas sino que muchos
piensen y se planteen Por qué Porque
tengo que arriesgar mi vida para seguir
pidiendo y protestando por eso cada una
de esas generaciones ha tenido decenas y
decenas de exiliados de jóvenes
especialmente que han buscado un futuro
por fuera del país y esta no es la
excepción está Tal vez es uno de los
momentos en los cuales más jóvenes
iraníes están saliendo Pero también
dicen aquellos que vienen de otras
generaciones que está tal vez en la
generación más violenta más más más
valiente la que ha perdido Más el miedo
y eso también está liderado por esas
mujeres jóvenes que vemos en la la calle
ellas son las que más sufren esa
violencia esa inseguridad cada vez que
salen de sus casas y son las que han
perdido ese miedo para salir a protestar
Y esto es lo que hace esta protesta
diferente esta protesta se liderada por
las mujeres pidiendo por su seguridad
pidiendo por sus derechos y muchos de
esos jóvenes que están en la calle
también las están apoyando
Catalina usted que está allí entera en
la capital de Irán como es el día a día
en esa relación entre la mujer iraní la
mujer de la ciudad la mujer del campo y
esta policía de la moral que el tanto
tiene esta relación de ingredientes de
persecución de miedo o en cierta forma
también de protección hacia la mujer
esa policía la moral está básicamente
presente en las grandes ciudades del
país y especialmente
enteraban donde cada vez tienen más
presencia especialmente en glorietas en
lugares de mucho tráfico de personas y
especialmente a las salidas de los
metros Así que la relación de las
mujeres especialmente esa clase media
que todos los días tiene que salir a la
calle [__] el transporte público ir a
las universidades en los trabajos es
bastante frecuente y de ahí que el
rechazo y la rabia de muchas de esas
mujeres porque muchas dicen Mire yo yo
yo llevo bien el velo yo llevo bien la
gabardina Tal vez un poco caído Tal vez
tal vez el pantalón un poco pegado pero
aquí no hay una razón específica por la
cual nos capturan muchas veces
simplemente es el criterio de cada una
de esas policías que está en ese lugar y
cada vez esa actitud de esa policía Es
algunas veces más violenta hemos visto
muchos vídeos a lo largo de estos años
cebollas arrestan a las mujeres con
violencia especialmente aquellas que se
niegan a ser capturadas Así que la
relación es de mucha presencia la ven
todos los días y por eso hay cada vez
más rabia hacia esa policía de la moral
y Es bien interesante lo que ha pasado
en los últimos días la han sacado de las
calles la comisaría donde llevaron a
Maxi América es donde llevaban a todas
las mujeres está cerrada y aquí es la
gran pregunta es seguirá existiendo le
dará ese crédito la República islámica
la población que está protestando y
sacará a la policía la moral de las
calles eso sería como la gran pregunta a
responder ahora Catalina pues muchas
gracias por esta actualización desde
terreno desde la ciudad de Teherán
Gracias por esta actualización desde la
capitalidad iraní Entonces vamos a
analizar este tema y para ello hemos
invitado a Zaida membrado ellas
periodista también fue corresponsal allí
en la República islámica ya se encuentra
en Barcelona en la capital catalana en
España y también desde la ciudad de
Madrid
se conecta a esta conversación Marta
González isidoro también periodista y
analista política especialista en medio
oriente recuerde que ustedes pueden
dejar todos sus comentarios a través de
las redes sociales ustedes ya las
conocen estamos en instagram en Twitter
en Facebook y también pueden escuchar en
la transmisión de este programa a través
de nuestro streaming en YouTube y pueden
volver a oír este episodio de otros
episodios del debate a través de
nuestras publicaciones en nuestros
podcast estamos en Apple podcast en
Spotify deezer y TuneIn
Pues muy bien voy entonces Al Punto de
partida Como me gusta Llamar a la
primera pregunta para conocer posiciones
de los invitados le doy la bienvenida
entonces a Zaida membrado Zaida Gracias
para acompañarnos en el programa Y
piensa usted entonces que este es un
punto de quiebre para la sociedad iraní
que estas manifestaciones no son como
las manifestaciones que hemos visto de
la sociedad de iraní en los últimos años
Cuál es su análisis
bueno
El Punto de partida está claro que es un
Punto de partida muy muy especial Porque
es la muerte de una chica de una forma
que todavía se desconoce exactamente qué
pasó y no parece que se vaya a saber no
parece que el gobierno vaya a ser
transparente porque transparente
significaría probablemente admitir que
ha habido pues una paliza o que ha
habido un maltrato y que esa chica murió
a manos de la policía pero hay que hay
que pensar que no es la primera por
supuesto mujer que muere por Pues bueno
pues a causa de la de la violencia
impune que ejerce en este Lo que pasa
que al viralizarse esa imagen en el
hospital sin esa imagen probablemente
esa muerte quizá hubiera quedado
totalmente silenciada pensamos que como
comentaba Catalina es una es una chica
que no viene de ninguna clase alta es
una chica curva currdistán es un
territorio totalmente enfrentado con el
sistema con el régimen por tanto el
hecho de que incluso su origen nos haría
pensar que bueno que no es nadie más a
mí no era nadie para el gobierno pero
cuando Se realizaron esas imágenes y se
vio que esa chica Estaba sin constantes
vitales en el hospital eso fue una
chispa que desató la cólera de una
sociedad hombres y mujeres que ya no
pueden más no que están O sea que hay un
límite y yo creo que eso hizo que se
desbordara entonces la diferencia con
otras protestas es lo que ahora todo el
mundo se pregunta si va a llevar a algo
diferente porque en 2019 hubo unas
protestas multitudinarias en Irán a raíz
del aumento de el precio de la gasolina
y bueno la devaluación de la moneda
etcétera y hubo muchísimos muertos
de los que se están registrando hasta
ahora es verdad que duraron más y nada
cambió no entonces la cuestión es Cuál
es la diferencia desde luego el
detonante lo que ha hecho es que
muchísimas mujeres hagan algo insólito
que es que juntas se manifiestan sin
velo esto no había pasado nunca en esa
magnitud Pero y para mí la pregunta
clave es Si eso va a desencadenar en
algo distinto o cuando las cámaras y el
foco internacional se apague el gobierno
vaya a actuar como normalmente hace no y
es de una manera que por detrás mantiene
su Bueno pues su impunidad y su
autoritarismo Claro ya vamos a analizar
esos dos puntos ahí ya lo tengo dentro
de la agenda para discutirlo en el
programa le doy la bienvenida ahora a
Marta González y también el mismo Punto
de partida porque estas manifestaciones
Marta Bienvenida al programa son
distintas a lo que estamos
habitualmente que vemos en las pantallas
de lo que sucede en Irán Y
si este es un punto de quiebre para la
sociedad iraní Esto va a asentar un iba
a ser un antes y un después
Hola buenas Buenas noches buenas tardes
para para ustedes estoy de acuerdo con
el análisis que habéis hecho la
introducción y que ha hecho también
Zaida Yo creo que la muerte de masa de
masa a mini no es no es un caso aislado
todo lo contrario forma parte de un país
que utiliza el control y la vigilancia
de una policía específica para
implementar y para que hacer que se
cumplan a rajatabla esas normas sobre la
vestimenta que implementó se
implementaron con gran dureza a partir
de la revolución de
1979 pero más allá de la de la
vestimenta yo lo que creo Es que hay yo
lo que creo que hay una realidad más
material y que la mujer la situación de
la mujer depende de factores políticos
económicos
animales que trascienden a este hecho
específico que que se ha producido y que
ha dado la vuelta al mundo precisamente
porque hay cámaras de delante yo creo
que sin caer en la en la Euforia y en
Euforia excesiva y sobre todo Para no
caer en aquello que caímos los los
analistas cuando tuvieron lugar las
primaveras árabes creo que sí
efectivamente estamos asistiendo a algo
nuevo a una exhibición sin precedentes
de la de ira de la ira popular pero
contra el régimen teocrático pero
efectivamente
esta revolución de liyab que sea que se
que se ha nombrado o contra esta forma
de actuar contra la policía de la moral
efectivamente estamos viendo por primera
vez que hay actos de desobediencia y
otros ataques directos
la dependencia sobre todo y símbolos de
gubernamentales que demuestran por
primera vez a mi juicio que la situación
que la sociedad iraní y sobre todo las
mujeres están perdiendo el miedo como
habéis dicho en la introducción y una
sociedad que pierde el miedo es una
sociedad ingobernable Y eso es
precisamente lo que creo que asusta a
este régimen que está en un momento
geopolítico complicado y que puede ver
que el mundo que se está dividiendo en
este momento entre los dos focos entre
los aquellos que
apoyan el derecho internacional y las y
los países más revisionistas puede estar
en peligro pero yo sería cauta Marta
un poco más puntual porque se extiende
mucho son muy pocos minutos de programa
y tengo mucho para analizar pasó a darle
la palabra a Zaida membrana membrado en
la ciudad de Barcelona para contarle
para terminar de organizar como las
piezas para entender que lo que está
sucediendo en Irán es un país muy
particular pero precisamente por esas
sanciones que hay a nivel internacional
eso lo ha llevado a que se cierre un
poco y sea muy difícil obtener
información allá de primera mano para
terminar de organizar esta idea del
Punto de partida Zaida qué otras cosas
ya Catalina mencionaba algunos puntos se
están sumando a la coyuntura iraní que
han dado pie a estas manifestaciones
ella mencionaba el malestar económico
también pero qué más está sucediendo
allí
bueno es que vamos a ver
Irán es no es una democracia no Entonces
esta gente Vive sin libertad pero la
principal preocupación no es esta sino
que es una mucho más primaria que es
poder pagar las facturas a fin de mes
puede ir al supermercado y tener una
esperanza de futuro cuando eso no existe
porque el paro está desbocado porque la
moneda local está totalmente devaluada
porque no hay esperanza en una sociedad
sumamente preparada Irán es particular
en Oriente medio hay que comprender que
es una excepción es tiene la tasa más
alta de universitarios es esa masa tan
amplia de gente muy joven que lo que
tendría que estar ahora es trabajando y
con la esperanza de conseguir una vida
plena lo que ve es que no tiene ningún
futuro Entonces eso Este es el detonante
principal a lo que se une Pues todo lo
demás que es la represión de no poder
tener no poder exhibir tu sexualidad de
no poder de no poder ser tú mismo no de
ser alguien dentro de casa y ser otra
persona totalmente distinta fuera de
casa por tanto si sumamos la falta de
libertades más esenciales junto con las
dificultades económicas tan bestias que
hay que hay sino pues un caldo de
cultivo tremendos y en ese sentido es lo
que para mí es el factor que que no ha
cambiado Pese a que las sanciones en su
momento se levantaron con el acuerdo
nuclear ya que usted lo menciona firmado
con Barack Obama pero cuando Trump sale
de este acuerdo Los harían ya entonces
Irán dice muy bien Donald Trump Sale
pues nosotros también salimos y
empezamos a Bueno a avanzar en el
enriquecimiento de uranio
etcétera entonces todo eso es elementos
que hacen que nadie tenga Esperanza
ninguna persona no que tenga una vida
más o menos pues que no sea rica no que
no pertenezca a la clase privilegiada y
todo esto es son los elementos que
Unidos hacen que cualquier de donante y
este no es menor la muerte de una joven
pues pues ahí han estallado claro Marta
para entender también este Punto de
partida de entender la situación
dinámica creo que dado el caso que que
nos está explicando salida de lo
particular que es la sociedad de iraní
que es una sociedad educada es un país
industrializado donde pese a hacer una
República islámica una teocracia que no
cumple valores democráticos desde el
punto de vista de occidente tiene muchas
ventajas y particularidades para la
mujer
pensar si lo comparamos con otros países
musulmanes de la región Cuál es el papel
que tiene la mujer en la sociedad iraní
Cómo es el papel y cómo es Esta división
de poderes o cargas entre los hombres y
las mujeres en Irán
bueno legalmente la mujer está
considerada como menor de edad y está
continuamente tutelada desde las
instituciones desde la propia
Constitución el código de familia y el
consejo de la Revolución que son los que
realmente tienen El poder legislativo
importante y el poder de veto en la
Constitución hay un consenso entre todos
los partidos políticos incluso entre
aquellos que son más aperturistas y que
pretenden o que abiertamente están de
acuerdo a un favorecer
la igualdad de las mujeres en que no es
un momento adecuado para hacer cambios
porque podría tambalearse el régimen Y
ninguno de los partidos incluso los
oficialistas están Están en contra de la
caída del régimen Es cierto que la mujer
en Irán es una mujer muy educada una
mujer que no está constreñida al espacio
físico del país en el que vive viaja
tiene acceso a internet y tiene las
mismas preocupaciones que tenemos las
mujeres en occidente por lo tanto unido
a esa nueva generación de La que hablaba
Zaida que ve como sus expectativas
económicas han cambiado están frustradas
que ven que además a nivel geopolítico
toda la región está dando pasos
agigantados en un en un sentido de
cambiar ese o por lo menos de dejar a un
lado los estigmas ideológicos que han
caracterizado a las generaciones
anteriores Yo creo que el papel de la
mujer Unido también al papel que tienen
los movimientos feministas
internacionales que son muy activos
hacen que la mujer en en Irán tenga un
papel clave en la sociedad civil
algo para complementar en torno el tema
del papel de la mujer en la sociedad y
le extiendo un poco más la pregunta para
seguir profundizando y es entendiendo
Entonces ese papel de la mujer iraní y
teniendo estos componentes particulares
de este país Cómo es la relación entre
el estado y la mujer
pues es una relación de sometimiento no
porque cuando tú por ley estás
considerada un ser inferior un ser que
estás bajo la tutela de tu marido de tu
hermano en cualquier caso un ser
masculino poco te queda Entonces cuando
se habla de machismo o de que la
sociedad iraní es patriarcal no es solo
un tema cultural y es que una sociedad
acostumbrada a Bueno a que la mujer Pues
tenga un papel muy específico pues se
ocupe de la familia lo que todos sabemos
sino que por ley hasta hace poco
atropellar a una mujer era más barato
que atropellar a un hombre eso qué
significa significaba que la
indemnización que había que pagar en el
caso de que la víctima fuera un hombre
era mucho mayor que si la víctima era
una mujer cómo se justifica porque se
cree que el hombre es quien aporta el
dinero y sostiene la familia por tanto
que un hombre muera las consecuencias
para esa familia son mucho mayores claro
Esto está escrito Qué más pues bueno el
divorcio tiene que alegar una causa en
particular Pues si Solicito el divorcio
un debe apoyar mi causa que tiene que
ser o bien que mi marido tiene otra
esposa o bien que en principio no está
permitida la monogamia en irá la
poligamia en Irán
o bien que me maltrata o se droga es una
adicto a las drogas entonces tengo que
alegar un motivo claro todo esto es la
relación que la mujer tiene con el
estado porque el estado la somete y por
ley le dice dónde tiene que colocarse y
cuáles son sus derechos entonces no es
solo en la calle como algo cultural de
yo tengo que llevar un hillab que lo que
ya está es diciendo que yo soy inferior
porque tengo que llevar una prenda que
ellos no deben llevar sino que por ley
está escrito que soy un ser que soy
dependiente y no soy autónomo Aunque
supere los 18 años Claro ya si tengo una
formación profesional y pueda trabajar e
incluso mantenerse económicamente Y ser
completamente Autónoma Zaida hago la
ronda la inversa continuó con usted y le
preguntó ahora a nivel internacional ha
habido muchísimas críticas por esta
situación que se ha presentado en Irán
en los últimos días a la muerte de esta
joven las manifestaciones y el papel de
la mujer en ese país y el trato que se
le da a la mujer pero la comunidad
internacional que más puede hacer más
allá de simplemente Elevar críticas
señalar al gobierno de la yatolá qué más
pueden hacer
Bueno cuando hablamos de comunidad
internacional sino referimos a la gente
normal como pueden ser la población de
los países occidentales que están más
que son más activos en Twitter y que por
tanto todo el mundo está retuiteando las
imágenes todo el mundo pide somos
No eso nosotros Más allá de eso nada
pero quienes podrían hacer algo son los
gobiernos son las Naciones Unidas y no
tengo ninguna duda de que no harán nada
por una simple razón porque a nadie le
interesa
tener ahora mismo o sea hay un acuerdo
nuclear pendiente de firmar que por
ahora están standby y por otro lado hay
intereses totalmente subyacentes a los
Derechos Humanos si accidente le
importaran los Derechos Humanos si las
Naciones Unidas o Estados Unidos le
importaran los Derechos Humanos habría
pasado algo después de Afganistán que
todo el mundo pareció que en ese momento
le importaban las mujeres afganas y está
claro que no le importan a nadie porque
ahí siguen los talibanes y al final es
un gobierno soberanos es un país no con
un gobierno soberano y un pueblo que
hacemos invadimos Cómo ayudamos a un
país para mí la única manera Es que
desde dentro haya una Revolución y los
proyectos iraníes sean quienes derroquen
si tienen que hacerlo ese gobierno no
solo yo quien lo diga no será un país No
será un tercer país qué queremos que sea
Libia que queremos que sea Afganistán
que sean que sea Siria que se convierta
en un tablero de tres países en una
guerra Proxy de tres países perdón de
tres frentes todo el mundo buscando sus
intereses Irán no es esto y no creo que
llegue a ser esto nunca Irán Si alguna
vez tiene que librarse de esa de esa
República islámica lo tiene que decidir
su propio pueblo por tanto desde fuera
básicamente Pues no sé Mostrar la
solidaridad porque ellos dicen o sea
para ellos es muy importante para la
gente joven el que nosotros estemos
tuiteando o estemos bueno que sean me
entiende que tengan esa presencia en el
exterior Pero eso no significa que
vayamos a ayudarles Marta así las cosas
entonces solidaridad por parte de la
comunidad internacional entendiéndose un
poco más como el mundo occidental pero
el destino de las mujeres iraníes están
sus propias manos en este momento y
están sus manos que ellas puedan dar un
paso adelante y conseguir algo o por lo
menos cambios o quedarse en lo mismo
el destino de las mujeres en Irán y el
destino de las mujeres en todo Oriente
medio y en los Países Árabes musulmanes
está en las propias manos de las mujeres
y de la sociedad civil que quiera por
medios
legítimos cambiar desde dentro las
instituciones y el sistema que las
oprime desde las propias constituciones
el régimen iraní Hoy está expuesto en
Naciones Unidas porque se Está
celebrando la asamblea general en
Naciones Unidas pero no creo yo no soy
en nada optimista coincido con el
análisis de Zaida no soy optimista en el
sentido de que Irán hoy es un actor
importante desde el punto de vista
político y geopolítico la Unión Europea
en particular tiene mucho interés en
mantener relaciones comerciales con Irán
por lo tanto la cuestión de las mujeres
y de los Derechos Humanos en Irán va a
seguir siendo un asunto secundario
mientras el asunto nuclear y a nivel
los problemas derivados de la
exportación del terrorismo y el apoyo a
los regímenes a las milicias más
revisionistas no se ponga no se ponga
freno por lo tanto
tiene que ser desde dentro que haya un
cambio Marta y qué piensa usted continuó
con usted para hacer la ronda la inversa
que haya estas manifestaciones en
Afganistán a raíz de la llegada al poder
nuevamente del talibán este escenario
que estamos viendo ahora en Irán
entiendo que la situación es
completamente diferente pero aquí vemos
son las mujeres saliendo a las calles
para reivindicar sus derechos y pedir
mejores condiciones de vida en sus
respectivos países se están empezando a
sembrar pequeñas semillas de mujeres de
las repúblicas islámicas de los países
musulmanes que piden más libertades
piden igualdad esto puede generar un
efecto bola de nieve podemos ver más
manifestaciones en otros países
no soy tan optimista Lo siento creo que
el tiempo de la Democracia de la
libertad de la liberación de las mujeres
en Afganistán terminó con el último
norteamericano y el último occidental
volando hacia Europa y con la llegada de
los talibanes en Afganistán creo que
estos movimientos son muy positivos
porque reflejan y ponen sobre el espejo
la realidad de unas mujeres que
realmente necesitan una Liberación y un
feminismo y no el feminismo de pancarta
al que estamos acostumbrados en los
países occidentales porque es muy fácil
Ser valiente Aquí cuando tu vida no
corre peligro Estas mujeres se enfrentan
a muchísimos años de cárcel cuando no a
latigazos o apenas de muerte por lo
tanto me gustaría ser optimista pero no
lo soy la cual es su opinión es poco
optimista así como la de Marta piensa
usted que son semillas de un posible
efecto de nieve a largo mediano plazo en
las diferentes las sociedades del mundo
musulmán
Pues coincido con Marta y no no soy
optimista porque cuando hay un gobierno
autoritario y no existe la posibilidad
de decidir ni de desde el pueblo generar
cambios que no estén Bajo La amenaza de
la violencia de los disparos de la
represión de las violaciones de Los
abusos y de todo lo que ya sabemos que
existen estos países pues entonces es
muy complicado Si vemos que ha pasado
con las primaveras árabes Cuál ha
triunfado cuando ha habido algún cambio
en positivo solamente túnez tuvo algún
cambio y esa Revolución había digamos
estaba también otro partido que subió al
poder que luego se demostró que era de
tendencia islamista O sea
no una una población que no tiene
democracia que no vive en democracia o
cae el gobierno o es muy poco lo que se
puede avanzar en derechos humanos y más
de las mujeres porque no son libre claro
y vemos la inestabilidad política que
precisamente está viviendo túnez en
estos días pasó ahora a preguntarles por
el otro lado de la moneda Zaida la
respuesta que puede tener el gobierno de
la República islámica la represión allí
es parte habitual el sistemático lo
hemos visto para estas manifestaciones
cosas como suspender el servicio de
internet o el servicio de telefonía
móvil simplemente para no coordinarse
entre los ciudadanos para estas
manifestaciones qué más se puede esperar
del
régimen de la yatolá
bueno como como bien ha mencionado el
cortar internet y cortar las
comunicaciones es lo principal que hace
el gobierno no es la primera vez y ya lo
hizo en su momento y en 2019 cuando esas
protestas de las que hemos hablado tan
masivas entonces Bueno si se hace eso
evidentemente los iraníes se quedan
totalmente sin capacidad de dar a
conocer lo que están haciendo en el
mundo de aliarse entre ellos eso ahora
que duran las protestas después Podría
tener algún gesto algún gesto de ceder
en algo pero eso con el gobierno actual
con el presidente Ibrahim Rising es
difícil de imaginarlo porque es un
presidente de karité totalmente
ultraconservador y por tanto yo no me
puedo imaginar más que cuando tenga la
oportunidad y ya no Y la asamblea de las
Naciones Unidas y todo lo que ahora todo
el foco internacional desaparezca Pues
habrá detenciones que ya las está viendo
y esas detenciones llevan a la cárcel y
lo que normalmente existen estos países
entonces acortar la comunicación de
internet desde fuera dejamos de ver
desde dentro dejan de poder aliarse y
luego las consecuencias son las propias
de un país que bueno que con impunidad
pues abusa de su gente con cárcel con
torturas con lo que normalmente existe
no me imagino con este gobierno con el
anterior podría ser que se llevara a
cambio algún tipo de que llevar a cabo
Perdón algún tipo de cambio favorable
para la población pero quiero Añadir que
el gobierno también está y el sistema a
la expectante no no está tranquilo
porque lo que está pasando es grave y
podría derivar en algo que no ha
ocurrido en 43 años y está un poco los
analistas también lo están considerando
Cómo va a acabar esto es que claramente
los gestos de la sociedad iraní en estos
últimos días han sido sumamente
desafiantes con el gobierno hemos visto
por ejemplo que queman no solamente el
velo como lo estaban haciendo las
mujeres sino que también han estado que
mandó imágenes de fundador de la
República islámica islámica de la
ayatolá alija meney que eso pues es un
mensaje muy fuerte por parte de los
ciudadanos hacia el gobierno quiero
trasladarles a ustedes dos Marta y Zaida
una pregunta que planteaba Catalina en
su intervención desde Teherán y es cuál
puede ser el futuro de esta policía de
la de la moral que fue precisamente la
que detuvo a esta joven de 22 años y que
según la los primeros indicios ella
murió estando bajo custodia policial de
este de esta rama de la policía iraní
Marta comienzo por usted a raíz de este
escándalo de todo lo que ha pasado qué
futuro le espera para este brazo de la
policía de iraní
No creo que cambie como como mucho como
apuntaban Zaira al principio
suavizará su actitud sobre todo porque
la comunidad internacional
ha visto la dureza por una por vez
primera la dureza con la que actúa esta
policía es decir los analistas las
personas que los periodistas in Sito las
personas que seguimos el día a día de
oriente medio y de la sociedad en
Oriente medio sabemos cómo funciona este
tipo de
instituciones represivas Pero ha sido
bueno que se pudiera ver también a nivel
internacional podría suavizar su
situación sobre todo de Cara a las
futuras negociaciones que el régimen va
a tener en los próximos días y en los
próximos meses de cara al acuerdo
nuclear y al levantamiento de las
sanciones que eso le interesa pero no va
a cambiar no va a cambiar la opinión de
Marta desde la ciudad de Madrid y en
Barcelona Zaida su opinión para el
cierre y conclusión
pienso igual que Marta no creo que la
policía de la moral desaparezca puede
que tenga una actuación menor pero no va
a desaparecer porque el estado necesita
reprimir es decir si esto desaparece
Pues el velo si ahora está algo suelto
todavía estará más suelto Entonces esto
la tendencia es bueno Hacia dónde quiere
ir la sociedad que es opuesta hacia
donde quiere ir el gobierno Entonces yo
lo que decía antes cuando he mencionado
el perfil ultraconservador del
presidente actual es que si no hay
acuerdo con occidente acuerdo nuclear
eso para el gobierno actual es un
pretexto para acusar a occidente de
boicotear El acuerdo nuclear de estar en
contra de Irán de atentar contra la
integridad del país por tanto casi que
prefiere que todo que no haya acuerdo
que
boicotearse a sí mismo no lo contrario
del anterior presidente rojani que hizo
lo que pudo para aprender puentes con
occidente Ahora yo lo veo mucho peor
pues ya veremos En qué termina esta
historia Seguiremos haciéndole
seguimiento para llevar aquí al debate
de France 24 del análisis de lo que
pueda ocurrir allí en Irán a Zaida de
amarte les agradezco mucho por haber
estado con nosotros Haber puesto en
perspectiva este tema importante y
destacado de la actualidad internacional
es todo por hoy en nombre de todo el
equipo técnico Les agradecemos su
sintonía la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Pedro Ruiz y la
producción de invitados estuvo a cargo
de Tania Herrera sigan dejando sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales y por supuesto en sintonía de
France 24
[Música]